after more than a year of isolation and
disconnection mental health remains
really a concern for students across the
valley
and although getting professional
treatment is beneficial kids sometimes
need
another avenue to seek help orco manage
joining us live with how some local
teens are getting involved to help each
other out
orca
well brian with kids stuck at home doing
distance learning away from their
friends
they often find it hard to describe how
they're feeling even to their parents
but when it comes to conversations about
mental health and suicide there are some
local organizations that are providing
peer-to-peer resources it's important
that we acknowledge mental health
and be there for each other a helping
hand during a tumultuous time
hope means nevada is a group focused on
stopping youth suicides
especially important now with more than
20 ccsd student suicides since the start
of the pandemic
15 year old sydney yee is part of the
teen committee and says their role
is crucial as teens we kind of connect
with each other more and feel more
comfortable
sharing with each other rather than like
a counselor or a teacher they host
events and provide tools such as their
ask
five initiative we should ask five
people we know how they're doing
to kind of get out there and check in on
our friends
there's always gonna be someone there
for you ye participating in a suicide
prevention panel thursday night focused
on empowering young people
there wasn't much for teenagers sienna
pranger started teens helping teens a
few years ago
she says peer-to-peer resources are also
key in actually encouraging those
struggling
to ask for help in the first place it
seems less like charity and
more like just someone being a friend
and i think that's really
important when it comes to them reaching
out themselves
the main goal is to come together we
should keep reaching out to each other
keeping there for each other and keep
loving each other
we'll have the contact information for
both of these organizations on our
website 8newsnow.com
reporting live tonight orco mana 8 news
now